abone ol
Allah
[Alkış]
sizi arkadaşlar
o yıllar yıllar yıllar öncesiydi
küçük küçük
bu ederiz saç fırçası bakın karşısında
şarkılar söylüyor
kelime bakıyordu
sonra sonra dönüp okuduğum kitapları
Romanların okuduğum Romanların
kahramanları kahramanları takip ediyorum
mesela dosya sistemi
canlandırıyordu
gidiyordu bana diyordu ki ders var mı
o Herkes bana diyor ki
O
da iç ver şimdi bu kesin tartılacak
falan diyorlar Hatta Bununla ilgili bir
geçmişe dönelim iki dakikalık size
çocukluğumla ilgili videolar onun şey
yapacağım
Yok yok
böyle bir şey söyleyeyim
be ne olmak istediğim ve ne yapmak
istediğini bilmiyorum ama böyle başladı
böyle başarılı insanlar vardır
hayatlarında başarılı insanlar vardır
derler ki Evet ben aynanın karşısında
satılık silah şarkı söylüyordum ya da ne
yapıyorduk yapabilir Bunlar da başarılı
olan insanlarda saygı duyuyorum tabii ki
ama öyle değil Arkadaşlar
takip
ama
arkadaşlarım anlattılar devam ediyor
galiba yuvarlak of of
bu Mustafa girdim sadece sadece derdim
şuydu
yuvarlak şeyleri taşıma Optik bak
videolarda hop Gayet saygılı şey yapıyor
zaman Ama bir sorun olmaz falan diye
uzun 4 yanlış 1 doğruyu götürdüğü
ucundan şu geçmiyor ben yazar Oyuncu
olacağım hiç bilmiyorum Sadece
doldurdum
yaşıyorduk
Hattuşa Hattuşa ve
[Kahkaha]
bu sefer en son tercih Bu arada sizin
doğru söyleyim yani böyle büyük bir şey
olabilirdi bir şey olabilir sözelciyim
Ben kazandım ama bu
söylemiş aldı vardı benim ve ben
İstanbul
Ankara aktarmalı o zamanlar utc saat
4.00 5.00
saat 1'de
ben oradayım
Üniversitesi güzel gidiyor şöyle okumaya
başlıyoruz Hatta Doğu Ekspresi tren de
gelirken Arkadaşlar şöyle birşey oldu
aletler için biliyorsun kitap oku şu
yapalım giderken Hatta
15 yıl 15 saatlik
yolculuk
kitaplardan o
O çok başarılı olanları işlerinde
onların onlarla ve onları çağırdı bir
dergi vardı sahip aile hikayesi vardı
işte bir hikaye çok güzel hikayedir
verdi nereden duyarsan duy nereden
gelirse gelsin bir hiç sesi duyduğunda
işte pis hiç der alıp olarak yine işlemi
vermiş oluyordu benim Grup arkadaşım
onların yanına gittim şimdi kaynamaya
başladı şimdi şeyleri veriyor bunu da
tavsiye olsun biraz da söylemiyor
tavsiye
söyleyeceğim okulda mezun olmak
gerekiyor şimdi şöyle bir şey vardı Ben
Yaşamadım ama ben duydum anlatıyorum
size bizim okulda o zaman meşhur
herkesin konuşuyordu
Ben 20 kişi mezun olacak bu dinlemesini
olur yani mezuniyet olursa beş kişi
olmuş yani
sınav sorusu şu arkadaşlar Bu kris nedir
Ama artık 19 işte yapmış ona kadar hiç
bu dur dur dur dur Niye bu sayfa 580
sayfa 40 sayfası sadece bir kişi boş ne
yaparmış
budur
ve gerçekten
biliyor musunuz tek kişi mezun oldu Ne
güzel ya
[Müzik]
ya Niye onlar gibi oluyor yani birileri
üzerinden bir de olmak çok zor bir şey
değildi sanatçıları şimdi sana da
özgürlük saat Özgür oluyor sana kendin
olmak da kendini kendimizdir ben sana
tercih edeceksiniz Eğer ucunu Eğer resmi
ve sanat ya da yazalım tercih
edecekseniz kendinizi Çünkü şöyle bir
şey vardır ve her zaman bunu ben böyle
kendime
İlke edinmiş indir söyleyeyim oluşudur
yazar Yazar Olmak
bu ne yazdığını değil nasıl yazdığımı
önemli işte bu dokusu belirler
arkadaşlar üslubunuz olmadı kendiniz
olması Gel şu şekilde zaten mı
da genişletti ve büyüktü ve kendim
olmaya gayret gösterdi beni o derde
yazmaya başladığımda belki uçuş okuyor
yüz kişi okuyordu Ama sonra ben Umut bir
hayat biçimi bir hayat felsefesi
olduğunun farkına vardım vardım
gerçekten ve para için Samimi söylüyorum
Bana yalan söylüyorsun yalan söyleme ne
şöyle
hiçbir şey seçtim
çünkü o kadar mutluyum ki
o gerektiğini her zaman söylüyorum
söylüyorum ve Unutmayın ki kendi olmanın
getirisi de şunu bir özgürlük alanı Yani
bu özgürlük alanlarını ne olur ki ne
olur kendinize kısıtlamadan salıya
şeymiş ise özgürlük varsa
arkadaşlar aşkla vardır o özgürlük varsa
yaşadığı yer öldürse sende Özgür bunları
Tabii benim uydurduğum şeyler değil yani
güzel çünkü bunlar olmanızı gerçekten
özgürlük alanı ve kendini olmak işimizi
ve sitemizi Seçtiğiniz zaman mutlu
olacağımızı düşünüyorum Bu yazı seni ben
de biraz daha videolar çek nasıl Niye ne
yazdın diye sorarsanız
versin işte felsefede İşte o mezun oldu
Biz olamadık o
hikâyesinden dolayı
bizdeki o zaman tartışıyorduk gerçekten
süt beyaz mıdır siyah mıdır filan diye
böyle böyle
kafa yediğimiz yazabilir saçmaladım
önemli oluyor Ben yanlış yazdım
tartışmaya başladığımda genelde bu
bölümün gerektirdiği bir şey biraz daha
uzaklaş ayım şu çok ağırlaşmaya başladı
Benim için böyle Peker Felsefe hayatı
Psikolojinin Anne ben biraz daha dedim
sana da Emine biraz şimdi yazıyor Tamam
şimdi yazmaya başladım önce kitabında
ölümün önsözü çok ağır o
bu tavsiye gibi dergilerde yayınlandı
içinde biraz şey
şiir formatında da bilmiyor falan yani
kendimi iyi hissediyorum
Allah'ım ya
ve bunların geçiriyorum sonra şairleri
tanımaya başladık en güzel oldu röportaj
yapmaya başladı
görüyorsunuz
Çünkü o
Yok ya bir şey söyleyeyim mi İbrahim
defterler Tamam
oyuncu çok güzel arkadaşlar böyle hani
Beğenilmek için koşuyor kamera
karşısında Vallahi çok hoş bir şey
arkadaşlar varsa onlara bir tavsiye
olsun
oyunculukta kamera ara seni seviyorsa o
abone ol bu Türk Sen ne iş yapıyorsanız
yapın sana Park bozukluğu düzelttim sana
bir şey söylüyorum kendinizi
o kendi sunumunuzu kendi tarzınızı kendi
pişiriniz işimizin kendiniz oluşturup
başkaları olması demesinler Biraz önce
dediğim gibi var bir şey
ama gerçekten
ruhumdan haritasında o
bu geliyoruz
Ben sizin alacağınız de hazırlanıp
Geldiğim son
cümle bitti
Evet şu anda ki mutluluğun ve huzurun ve
hayat sevenle alakalı işini çok sevmem
ile alakalı yazdıklarım ve oynadıklarını
Dayı ben versin ediyorum arkadaşlar
dersin abi
[Müzik]
[Alkış]